um what's going on
um I feel like we when we talk what is
uh is there anything new going on that
we should get out there with Armenia I
saw recently like Azerbaijan was
stirring [ __ ] up a little bit again yeah
it's like an ongoing conflict you know
what I'm saying um it's still going on
but it's I I believe it's kind of calm
right now
um Russia is trying to like mediate and
[ __ ] but this is like a conflict that's
been happening for like 30 years on and
off but then it was quiet for a long
time and then a couple years ago
um really in the middle of the pandemic
right right got like attacked out of
nowhere and then you know basically they
were trying to take over well first
there was this piece of land and I won't
go too deep into it because it gets
common we talked about it a bit before
yes if this piece of land called uh Arts
which is like
kind of within Azerbaijan but it's like
it's a Armenian city right yeah and it's
always a fight over that piece of
country and when the USSR broke up they
gave it to Azerbaijan even though it was
Armenian you know what I mean like on
some divide and conquer type [ __ ] Stalin
did that you know right
um so it's ongoing so then there was a
ceasefire then they attacked again and
the thing is like Azerbaijan is backed
by turkey
which there's a whole history there with
the Armenian Genocide and they're like a
powerful country yeah turkey's no no
Schmucks yeah and and compared to
Armenia you know we can use some help
you know what I'm saying how big of a
deal was it I was gonna say because
speaking of the turkey thing like Joe
Biden acknowledging The Armenian
Genocide as the first president to ever
do that how big of a deal is that look
it was a big deal we All For One Day
celebrated and then we heard that Joe
Biden is
giving military aid to like Azerbaijan
or through turkey or whatever you know
what I'm saying so it was kind of like
hey thanks but [ __ ] you that yeah
exactly yeah which you know honestly
that's what we kind of used to at this
point you know what I mean now because
because I was talking to my boy s dot
about this because we were in Detroit
and uh and Shout out all my people in
Detroit that's like my second home of
course right you've been out there
you've been running around in a sprinter
out there I think yeah they take care of
me over there but there's a lot of um I
don't even want to [ __ ] up the ethnicity
of people that's out there Chaldeans
Chaldeans albanians Chaldeans a lot of
Arabic Middle Eastern right so we went
to a store and the guy was like there's
all this like Middle Eastern candy and
the guy was like oh this is the Turkish
candy bar you should try it and I've I
looked at that stuff
and I was like actually I bought it
he was like Esther like you better not
dog he's like I won't eat that and I was
like I'm gonna try it bro what if it's
fire like nah it's all good like I threw
the candy bar away the thing like I grew
up in Amsterdam right it was almost no
Armenians I didn't have a single
Armenian friend growing up
um and I lived there till I was 18 and
it was a lot of Turkish people right
Netherlands Germany
so automatically you know you have
friends that have basketball teammates
and [ __ ] like that and they didn't even
know about this they don't understand
it's not it's not about the Turkish
people it's all love you know what I
mean it's about the government but we
don't support [ __ ] that's like made in
Turkey you know what I mean if I see
something that like Zara that says made
in Turkey I'm saying Zara because
they're known for having [ __ ] in Turkey
right
but you'll you do you know Turkish
people who sympathize with what happened
to Armenia yeah I don't I don't really
know a lot of Turkish people personally
now right you know what I'm saying when
I was a kid yeah so I don't really know
but yeah you see people come along along
your timeline like I always wondering
that like if there's like some kids in
Azerbaijan it's like our country's
[ __ ] up no absolutely yeah
absolutely have people like that but
it's also they didn't really have a
freedom of speech and like the the media
whatever journalists again locked up if
they if you know what I mean it's that
kind of contract some Russia type [ __ ]
exactly you can't just talk about you
know against the government like Iran
right now there's like a rapper in Iran
that's like lots more like you know what
I mean Iran's [ __ ] wild and they want
to give him like the death penalty I saw
that they were trying to like uh murder
like 15 000 protesters yeah insane it's
insane nice shout out to come on people
in Iran for real